it's been a week and chamber has finally
arrived in our ranked games valerian's
newest agent is here to shake up the
meta and after living through the
experience of everyone picking chamber
every single game we probably should
talk about him did riot finally deliver
on his promises do we finally have
another viable operator agent besides
jet
[Music]
all right y'all before i get into the
video i gotta remind you as always to
hit the like button the subscribe button
and to ring that notification bell
if you don't just like you me i'm gonna
latch on to you and be with you always
all right folks i know we are all super
excited for vct champions but before
that we have a new agent
[Music]
chamber
chamber was released for everyone to
play on november 16th as a part of patch
3.10 and besides his very interesting
lore including it being implied he had
something to do with what happened on
fracture
i think he's a pretty dope agent he is
the french gentleman of your dreams just
look at that bone structure but more
importantly his kit makes him stand out
from any other sentinel as a resident kj
main i was actually super excited to see
another sensor added to the squad and
was even more excited when i saw his kit
it's different from say a sage or cipher
but he's still a sentinel is he a
typical sentinel no but that's what riot
wanted in the first place in a press
release a character producer said we
started by thinking about different ways
to approach the sentinel role early on
our thought process wrapped around the
idea of someone that bunkers down and
holds a location by getting frags as we
worked on chamber the evolution of
someone who can hold down a site with an
array of weapons emerged between your
loadout his pistol slash ult and gadgets
a player should be able to hold down a
location
but it's up to you to use the tools
correctly and creatively so what exactly
does chamber do his signature ability or
e is his rendezvous or teleport anchors
when you're in range and on the ground
you're able to teleport to the anchor
also these anchors can be redeployed and
you can tp again after a cool down shout
out to yoru still waiting for his buff
his q or headhunter is essentially
equipping a sheriff that you have to buy
ammo for max 8 bullets here's what
shazam thinks about the look of this
what's going on this guy's like this
this guy's walking around like he's
wanna pull up
look at this his c or trademark is a
little trap that scans for enemies and
when enemies are detected it will deploy
a slow field after a countdown pretty
close to an alarm bot and finally his
alt also known as tour de force equips a
sniper rifle that kills on any direct
hit and after a kill creates a slow
field around where the person just died
so technically we have another op agent
like jet is he the most viable candidate
for opping
it depends on who you ask jet has been
the most beloved for op-ing because her
dash can make a quick getaway
chamber's tp technically can do the same
thing chambers op is a little bit
different in that a direct hit is a kill
but with the regular off if you hit
someone in the legs that's only 120
that's enough to kill someone who has
full health and shields also chambers op
is much louder than a standard op that
thing literally hurts my ears in game
but is he too similar to jet because
they both have a quick getaway short
answer
no lots of asians have blinds smokes
there will always be similar abilities
between agents and little tweaks here
and there to help differentiate them but
if you really want to get into the nitty
gritty of it let's compare jet and
chambers signature abilities her dash
and his tp and before you ask jet
technically has the faster movement
according to this video jetstash takes
about 1.09 seconds while chambers tp
takes 1.27 seconds but that doesn't mean
chambers tp isn't incredibly effective
like let's say you're anchoring like
right here okay
and you're anchoring
and you're kind of holding
main
anchoring boom you get one full
and gone
dude his teepee could be really helpful
for you when you try to get out of
trouble like how asana demonstrates here
again
let's play no i don't want to play
or as i demonstrate not very good for
you
so going back to my original point about
op agents chambers tp by default makes
him a viable op agent i asked average
jonas during his stream the other day
and he agrees that chamber is an op
agent and when i asked him about jet
versus chamber he said that at the end
of the day chamber is still a sentinel
by nature i definitely think the chamber
is an arp agent yeah jet is much better
on attack
chamber is still sentinel
but i'm excited to see him in probably
but if you're like wait euro is a tp
what about him as an op agent well
shazam said about two months ago before
chamber was released that jet was the
only viable operator agent the op is
only viable in jet and that's a problem
in my opinion it's too clunky to use on
any other agent so yoru is not
everyone's favorite agent to op on and
we now literally have an agent that says
here's an op go nuts so should you pick
jet or chamber to op
kind of an important question in my
opinion what it comes down to is team
comp economy and player ability chamber
directly rewards good aim two
visibilities are guns if you don't have
good aim or just having a bad day you
won't be using chamber to his full
potential so talk to your team if they
aren't toxic toddlers and work it out
but what do pro players think about him
i asked a couple on stream and the ones
who actually saw in my chat had pretty
muted reactions
uh
he's i8 i guess and chair is an op agent
like jet i don't know
i think he's gonna be pretty good on
twitter your boy dre said that the share
seems like it has aim assist flexsin
just showed off chambers alt on defense
and said that he likes his ult better
than a regular op
beautiful that's one kill my allies
hi easy peasy i was actually kind of
sick using his ult is really cool it
feels so much better than a normal
operator it shoots faster too that's
what i noticed my go to val twitter at
valor leagues asked people what they
thought about chamber
and the reaction seemed pretty mixed
some people loved him saying that
chamber is the best of both worlds
others thought he was just all right so
again a pretty muted reaction from what
i can tell he's pretty cool but if he's
not your play style or just not your cup
of tea then
that's pretty much it and this my dears
is what it comes down to because util is
good for specific things like all agents
i mean i know when i place i know i set
up my stuff i sit back site and i go on
my phone with chamber allows you to have
more freedom on the site to go play
aggressively even when you're
solo on that site and playing retake
and you can still kind of not like grief
your teammates by just going for one and
dying you get your one then you get out
and then you can be taking a 5v4 he
caters himself to specific players it's
really just up to you and if you want to
play him what might incentivize you to
play him or even just try him is economy
wise he has his pocket guardian hand
cannon whatever you want to call it
and it could be easily abusable each
bullet costs 100 credits 8 bullets max
and so you don't have to half-buy like
we all normally do
sometimes that is very much depending on
your team and your ability
but especially at higher elos and pro
level that could be game changing listen
to lothar explain this economy like you
buy small shields and like let's say
four bullets right which is 800 and
that's good enough
for a half by round
because if you go for a full duel
and you don't kill with someone with
four bullets from a sheriff you're dead
anyway where you would have to spend 1.2
k
for a sheriff and small shields to get
exactly the same outcome we won't see
him in champions we won't seem in pro
play until 2022 and pro players got a
whole different dimension to how we play
chamber my favorite part about chamber
is that he actually may encourage
players to play a little bit differently
maybe chamber will encourage people to
anchor sights more often or even help
with cross replacement with their two
guns in my opinion if an agent or any
character doesn't add anything new to
the game or to the experience of the
player
i'm not interested chamber is fun useful
and exciting is he the perfect agent or
even the perfect sentinel
no
but it's hard to be a perfect agent to a
community of millions avalorant lends
itself to all kinds of different players
and this is just one of those examples
if my agent excel spreadsheet has taught
me anything chamber will be patched as
time goes on to fit our needs and as the
meta changes will they patch your now
i don't know y'all i i how are you doing
your remains are you are you there are
there any left hello jokes aside the
point is go have fun with chamber play
as best you can and help your team out
you may be a chamber main you just don't
know it
okay
he looks even longer there he just looks
so long he's like
long boy
he's so big
you want to play let's play that's my
chamber first nation